[Música]
y nosotros continuamos en directo
América con revista de prensa nuestra
sección para hacer un repaso de cómo los
medios están cubriendo una noticia en
todo el mundo y hoy sin duda la noticia
es el funeral de la Reina Isabel II Para
eso me acompaña aquí en nuestro estudio
Marta Moya Marta bienvenida Buenos días
Buenos días María Clara Marta Comencemos
revista de prensa hablando de cómo los
medios impresos británicos están
hablando por supuesto de la monarca en
este último adiós y empecemos con metro
claro empezamos con metro todavía Pues
no ha habido ocasión de que la prensa
imprima las mejores partes de este
funeral de estado así que por supuesto
la prensa hoy es monográfica mitro que
es el periódico gratuito de mayor
circulación en Reino Unido dice gracias
señora un mensaje muy solemne con un
retrato de Isabel II Así es Y recordemos
que ma significa señora pero también
sonoramente es un juego de palabras con
la palabra madre en inglés cómo lo cubre
Daily telegraph el Daily telegraf
destaca en portada una foto pues que no
se había conocido hasta ahora de la
reina y bueno la hizo pública ayer la
familia real y dice una vida de servicio
desinteresado dice su presencia
tranquila y digna nos ha dado confianza
para afrontar el futuro con valor y
Esperanza Así es Marta y es que como
usted lo reseña ya sean conocido varias
fotografías a lo largo de estos 10 días
de funeral Y qué dice de independencia
de Independencia muestra pues una imagen
del féretro y dice Gran Bretaña llega a
un punto de inflexión haciendo un poco
de referencia pues al fin del luto
nacional y al fin de una era no que
supone este funeral de estado de Isabel
II y además ellos eligen una imagen el
que muestran los cuatro objetos que
acompañaron este ataúd y de San
también en un titular muy solemne dice
Dios la bendiga echaremos de menos esa
sonrisa y vuelve a destacar esta imagen
que hacía ayer pública la casa real dice
Su Majestad la reina en una encantadora
y un retrato no antes visto y divulgado
por la familia real ayer y Daily dice
nuestro último adiós y destaca las
palabras de ayer del Rey Carlos III
donde dice pues que se mostraba
conmovido al extremo por las muertes por
las muestras de afecto y cariño de la
sociedad británica Pues en torno a todo
este funeral de estado y este luto
nacional después de la muerte de la
reina Marta y sin duda es la noticia
Internacional del momento y por eso la
prensa internacional también ha dedicado
portadas y páginas enteras a este
entierro en Estados Unidos por ejemplo
de Washington post se pregunta por qué
el mundo está fascinado con Isabel
segunda Pues sí María Clara porque dice
que Isabel II era un programa de
televisión que todas las familias podían
destaca y hace uno obituario casi una
oda a la Reina Isabel II dice que era
una reina por la gracia de Dios una
madre y defensora de la fe la reina de
este reino y de otros muchos reinos
destaca el Washington post dice que se
encontraba a lomos de un siglo de
historia cataclísmica y de una familia
real en expansión famosa por su
disfuncionalidad
sensacionalista además Pues dice
destacar No pues que 500 jefes de estado
como veníamos diciendo han estado
presentes en este funeral y que pues las
ausencias y pues los miembros presentes
destacan un poco Quién es quién en la
escena internacional de Isabel II dice
además Pues que nadie cautivaba como
ella ni siquiera pues Los Reyes belgas
El Sultán de brunéide o pues los
miembros de la realeza del norte de
Europa dice por muy interesantes y
pintorescos que sean
y esta fascinación también llega a otros
medios internacionales incluso de habla
hispana como es el caso del país de
España que dedicó un reportaje a la
reina y la consideró La Reina del siglo
pop Así es Isabel segunda hizo no O sea
290 visitas de estado y visitó 117
naciones diferentes a lo largo de su
reinado entonces que fue también un
vínculo entre el pasado Pues que pues
que lo enlaza con el presente No de
Winston Churchill el primer el Primer
Ministro que invistió conectado Pues a
los Beatles y a la era del internet Dice
que la reina pues ha traspasado todos
los estratos de la cultura popular desde
alta cultura pues hasta Andy warhol o
Pues los sex pistols con esa versión que
le hacían del God save the Queen dice
que se convirtió en una que no se
convirtió Perdón en una celebridad Como
algunos de sus familiares y que siempre
permaneció por encima incluso para
aquellos que no son monárquicos dice
pues que Isabel segunda representaba esa
imagen de la cultura Popular en lo
cotidiano en los sellos en los billetes
se los juveniles pero también como
decíamos Pues en las grandes pinturas de
un pintor como warhol Y también fue un
icono femenino Marta pues la Reina
Isabel II fue reina después de una
monarquía en la que si bien había habido
otras mujeres femeninas la Reina Isabel
II sin duda marca la historia y de hecho
ahora tras su muerte la gran pregunta es
que rol van a desempeñar las mujeres y
lo veíamos un poco el anuncio en este
servicio religioso donde cuatro mujeres
tres de ellas religiosas participaron en
en la despedida un hecho que no se veía
antes por eso no es inhóspito que el
medio ainius de Reino Unido se pregunta
precisamente qué rol van a desempeñar
las mujeres en la casa real después de
la pérdida de la gran matriarca Así es
dice el director de la National portrait
gallery que Isabel II fue la mujer más
retratada de la historia y volviendo
pues daday news dice pues que ahora la
reconfiguración un poco de la casa real
que quiere impulsar Carlos III deberá
pues hacer ver qué rol van a jugar las
mujeres en esta Pues reconfiguración
dice que con la muerte de Isabel II pues
supone el fin del hogar matriarcal y que
pues ahora la corona británica está
regida por un hombre y también son
hombres los primeros en la línea de
sucesión dice pues que durante el luto
nacional tanto la Condesa de wessex como
en la nueva princesa de gales como la
princesa real Ana han jugado un papel
importante pero que ahora pues veremos
Cómo se reconfiguran estas fuerzas en el
interno de la casa real dicen analistas
citando este este análisis este informe
de aines Pues que con la partida de
Harry y de Megan de la familia real
activa o los escándalos del Duque de
York Andrés las mujeres se convierten en
sujetos valiosos que el Rey Carlos III
no debería subestimar
Gracias Marta y